we always talk about being a stable
company we talk about investing in
stable companies and you know are you
are you stable and you think about
stability stability is is an immobile
object
you know uh and and so uh companies that
are built for stability yes they're able
to weather storms but
they don't come out stronger or better
they just
come out they get through
building a company for resilience means
that you go into darkness but you're
actually able to adapt for new times new
technologies new cultures new politics
new tastes and you come actually out of
the hard times stronger than you went in
victorinox is a great example victorinox
many of us know them by their signature
product which is the old swiss army
knife and this company made
basically made a name for themselves on
this
basically one line of product they had
other product but this was this was the
core
and then something happened that they
couldn't predict nor could they uh
prepare for which is september 11th
happened
and
overnight
we were banned from taking their product
in our bags
in our hand luggager in our pockets we
so many of us used to carry a swiss army
knife in our pockets just throwing one
in our hand luggage like we all had one
you know every birthday for every
teenager they got at least one right um
every corporate gift you had a couple of
swiss army knives and now we were banned
from carrying them which means you're
less likely to buy one to give as a gift
and so their business their business
plummeted overnight
through no fault of their own through no
market conditions nothing predictable
but the genius of victorinox
is that they
were built for resilience
and what they did was they in good times
instead of giving away all the money in
big bonuses
in good times they actually saved a ton
of money and their attitude was
good times don't last but neither do bad
times and if we want to get through bad
times we need to have we need we need
cash and so instead of panicking and
taking loans or whatever it is they had
their own stack of cash that it that
they'd been hoarding so they had a
little financial resilience but then
they um looked at other products and
they asked their people to help build up
and they started investing heavily in
watches
now we have victorinox watches which are
much more and it's still swiss made
everything that they could do everything
that they knew how to do clothing
everything they leveraged their brand
heavily and they built it back up
also they protected all of their people
they actually made deals with companies
prior
that if bad times ever happened that
that other companies would borrow their
employees which i thought was genius so
they didn't lose their jobs they just
did their job somewhere else
and they completely reinvented their
company company now to this day their
swiss army knife never really recovered
it came up back a bit but it's now not
the major product is a minor product
that they sell because they actually
came out stronger and reinvented
and to be able to do that think about
that coming in as one kind of company
and coming out of another kind of
company very very rare and very very
special but very infinite minded